Все хотят чего-то добиться в жизни в
бизнесе в других сферах Вы стараетесь но
у вас не получается ну или получается но
не так много как хотелось бы всё это
потому что вы не понимаете благодаря
чему Мы чего-то добиваемся в жизни всё
чего мы добиваемся в жизни происходит
благодаря нашей силе это четвёртое видео
продолжающееся
суперпозиция - это про то как создать
такую ситуацию при которой тебе
закономерно везёт и весь мир хочет чтобы
ты добивался своих целей оставайтесь со
мной если хотите больше узнать об
[музыка]
этом все мы с детства знаем что такое
сила Мы всегда знали что самый сильный
человек - это папа Ну а потом мама потом
старший брат или
позже уже в детсаде мы уже замечаем что
сила у мальчика который постарше и
покрупнее по мере взросления мы начинаем
понимать что сила у того На чьей стороне
большинство дальше мы понимаем что сила
ещё бывает У того у кого есть орудие Ну
палка например мы начинаем понимать что
сила у того кто наделён властью А ещё
бывает сила у того На чьей стороне
правда позже в школе на уроках физики мы
уже лев начинаем изучать Что такое сила
мы с первого дня каждый день видим
проявление сил Мы видим что именно
благодаря силе происходят какие-то вещи
и события в этой жизни что-то вообще
двигается Так что же такое сила Давайте
вспомним уроки физики сила - это
векторная физическая величина которая
характеризует воздействие одного тела на
другое и приводит его к движению
изменению скорости или ускорению или к
его деформации А если сказать
по-простому то сила - это то что
заставляет тела двигаться изменять
скорость и деформироваться но это только
касается физических тел и объектов А как
же тогда человеческие отношения и не
физические процессы неужели там нет
силы конечно же есть мы ведь каждый день
видим различные проявления силы в нашей
жизни сила и законы силы действуют не
только в физике она действует и в
социальных отношениях и в психологии и
даже в том как Мы мыслим и очень важно
знать и понимать как проявляется сила в
этих сферах И каковы здесь законы силы
Сегодня мы и поговорим о том что такое
сила в более общем понимании и Как
видеть и использовать эту силу для
достижения своих целей этот ролик
продолжение цикла моих видео о
суперпозиции он будет полезен всем кто
хочет понять почему Одни люди буквально
из излучают силу и им легко даются цели
А другие люди прикладывают огромное
количество усилий а результаты всё равно
их не радуют Почему Одни люди выигрывают
всегда А другие проигрывают Как выглядит
сила в социальных отношениях И каковы
инструменты факторы и источники этой
силы короче сегодня мы наконец-то поймём
что законы описываемые в физике
применимы не только там Но их Также
можно применять и в социальных
отношениях психологии и в мышлении мы
поймём что законы присущие одной науке
также с успехом можно применять и в
другой сфере на самом деле Законы
Мироздания одни и те же они пронизывают
все сферы нашей жизни и физику и
математику и химию И психологию и
Социальные отношения а ведь бизнес и
любые формы деятельности направленные на
зарабатывание денег или для достижения
успеха это ведь социальная деятельность
основанное на мышлении психологии и
поведении поняв концепцию силы вы
поймёте что движет этим миром и что вам
нужно иметь прежде чем что-либо делать
или чего-то достигать подписывайтесь на
мой канал ставьте колокольчик активно
комментируйте и делитесь этим видео с
людьми Помогите сделать этот мир
эффективнее люди будут вам очень
благодарны Если же вы хотите получать
ещё больше таких знаний то
подписывайтесь на мой Telegram канал где
Я делюсь
о бизнесе инвестициях и
жизни для начала Давайте поймём Что
такое сила в социальных
отношениях сила - это способность
преодолевать
сопротивления видите в отличие от более
узкого определения в физике сила в
социальном аспекте имеет более широкое
значение как мы видим из этого оделения
- это
а зачем нам нужно преодолевать
сопротивление скажете вы чтобы достигать
своих целей и иметь ресурсы для
удовлетворения наших потребности Потому
что жизнь - это постоянная борьба борьба
за ограниченные ресурсы заметьте не за
нужные ресурсы А за ограниченные ресурсы
если ресурсы не ограничены то за них как
правило и не бывает борьбы например нам
всем жизненно необходи воздух во
солнечный свет Но мы же за них не
боремся соответственно для того чтобы
получить эти ресурсы нам не требуется
сила сила нам всегда нужна для борьбы за
ограниченные ресурсы Именно для этого
нам нужна способность преодолевать
сопротивление Откуда появляется
сопротивление сопротивление появляется
Со стороны других потребителей
ограниченных ресурсов или по-простому
сопротивление - это проявление
конкуренции или борьбы за ограничен
ресурсы именно для того чтобы всегда
побеждать в конкурентной борьбе нам и
нужна сила в чём привлекательность силы
для всех нас только в одном в том что
Только благодаря силе Мы можем с нуля не
имея больших ресурсов добиться
значительных успехов в жизни и всё Это
возможно благодаря мультипликаторам силы
или тому что умножает нашу силу либо
увеличивает эффективность той сил
которая у нас есть Как появляется сила
Давайте посмотрим это на примерах просто
Представьте себе что вы шланг или труба
через которую течёт вода вода - Это ваша
энергия при этом диаметр шланга или
трубы - Это то время которое у вас есть
Так вот диаметр изменить невозможно У
нас у всех одинаковое количество времени
в сутках соответственно в нашем случае
давайте представим что диаметр нашего
шланга равен 24 см Ну что отражает 24
часа в сутках так вот для того чтобы
иметь больше силы вам нужно либо
увеличить напор вашей энергии то есть то
С какой силой или усердием вы будете
качать или тратить свою энергию в данном
случае воду через этот шланг либо
концентрировать всю вашу энергию в одной
точке знаете Это как у пожарного шланга
наконечник есть который концентрирует
струю Таким образом мы видим что сила
появляется благодаря двум инструментам
Первое - это усердие или количеству
усилий которые мы прилагаем и второе -
это цели которые концентрируют все наши
усилия в одной точке или на одном
направлении к сожалению большинство
людей пытаются добыть ресурсы путём
простого увеличения усилий Это самый
простой и распространённый инструмент
этот инструмент доступен практически
каждому он не требует больших умственных
усилий но он требует большей
энергичности Однако этот инструмент
неэффективен у вас ограниченное
количество времени у вас ограниченное
количество энергии поэтому простое
увеличение усилий приводит лишь к
увеличению результатов только в
начальной стадии А в дальнейшем оно
приводит только к усталости выгоранию и
депрессии поэтому самым эффективным
способом обретения силы Будет сначала
выбор правильной цели а потом уже
максимальное приложение усилий в
направлении целей А как же знания
технологии и инструменты спросите вы А
как же правильный момент правильное
место и благоприятные обстоятельства
Давайте расставим все эти понятия по
своим местам чтобы ничего не висело в
воздухе Чтобы у вас было чёткое
понимание того что для чего и В какой
последовательности должно происходить
для этого мы должны сначала понять
простую последовательность
удовлетворения любых наших потребностей
первое для того чтобы удовлетворить наши
потребности нам нужно сначала определить
цель
это то о ЧМ я говорил выше цель - это
концентратор наших ограниченных ресурсов
который позволяет нам добиваться
большего за счёт меньшего второе нам
нужно приложить усилия потому что без
усилий невозможно добиться чего-либо
цель без усилий бессмысленна а усилия
без целий безрезультатные третье
благодаря тому что мы сконцентрировали
тепер все наши усилия на одной точке
благодаря тому что мы прикладываем
максимальные усилия на ней мы обретаем
силу четвёртое сила позволяет нам
преодолевать сопротивление и добиваться
ограниченных ресурсов пятое благодаря
полученным ресурсам или результатам мы
удовлетворяем наши потребности А теперь
Отвечая на ваш вопрос Что такое знания
технологии и инструменты в этом свете
так вот знания технологии и инструменты
- это лишь орудие достижения целей и
мультипликации результатов смотрите если
у Вас нету цели то любые знания
технологии и инструменты становятся
бессмысленными А значит
ненужными А как же насчёт правильного
момента места и благоприятных
обстоятельств Ну вы наверное уже сами
догадались что Если у вас нету цели то у
вас никогда не будет правильного момента
места и благоприятных
обстоятельств именно ваши цели
определяют то какое время место и Какие
обстоятельства благоприятны для этого
Поэтому правильное время место и
обстоятельства - это лишь факторы или
условия облегчающие вам достижение ваших
целей Как выбирать правильную цель Вы
уже поняли насколько важна сила и какую
роль в этом играет цель Как же вы
правильно выбирать цель какие критерии
Для этого нужны первое цель должна быть
значимой для вас она должна зажигать вас
именно цель даёт нам энергию второе цель
должна быть не просто значимой она
должна быть настолько значимой для вас
что отказ от всех других дел для вас не
составит труда по сути ваша цель должна
быть настолько конкурентоспособной по
отношению к другим целям что у других
целей просто нет шансов забрать Ваше
внимание вам должно быть Легко сказать
нет всему остальному помните основное
предназначение вашей цели - это быть
концентратором всех ваших усилий и
помыслов в одной точке вы знаете Я
размышлял над тем В чём разница между
успешными людьми и великими людьми так
вот Я понял такую вещь что успешные люди
- это люди которые превратили достижение
цели в привычку а великие люди это люди
которые поставили себе масштабные цели
которые настолько зажигают их что уже э
Великая цель диктуют им что делать и
таким образом делает этих людей великими
великими Люде делают не дела великими их
делают цели которые диктуют им то какие
дела им делать вот и всё что касается
выбора целей Поверьте мне если вы
преследуете не вашу цель или цель вам
навязана другими людьми или обществом
она не пройдёт по этим двум критериям
это два самых главных критерия которые
определяют то ваша цель или
нет Давайте подытожим для того чтобы
удовлетворить любые наши потребности и
достичь любых результатов нам нужна сила
сила - это способность преодолевать
сопротивление сопротивление возникает
из-за борьбы за ограниченные ресурсы для
того чтобы обрести силу нам нужны цель и
усилия цель без усилий бессмысленна а
усилия без целей
безрезультатный все остальные
инструменты и факторы - это только лишь
орудия и условия облегчающие нам
достижение нашей цели
либо увеличивающие эффект все Они не
имеют смысла если у нас не будет целей
или если мы будем преследовать не свою
цель своя цель должна отвечать двум
условиям первое она должна драйви и
зажигать нас она должна настолько
зажигать нас что ради неё мы можем легко
отказаться от всего
остального если мы будем иметь цель в
каждом нашем шаге и не будем совершать
бесцельный
если мы не будем упускать нашу цель из
виду и будем концентрировать всю свою
энергию и старания на ней у нас не будет
никаких преград которые мы не смогли бы
преодолеть помните что даже знание - Это
всего лишь инструмент достижения наших
целей поэтому не копите знания
преследуете целей Да пребудет с вами
сила H